[Music]
climate changes actually already
happened it's not something that we can
prevent at least fully at this point you
saw this with Hurricane Maria and most
recently with hurricane Michael that
we're just seeing more intense and more
frequent giant storms my question as a
researcher is how can we develop
technologies that help people adapt to
this new environment help people live in
a world that's already been affected by
climate change what people don't realize
is that a lot of this debris is actually
incredibly energy dense just raw lumina
m-- has 40 times the energy density of
lithium ion and 2 times the energy
density of diesel fuel so the idea is to
be able to take a part of your house
that was broken or a part of your car
like a wheel that you can't use anymore
and converting that into fuel that can
be used to provide water and electricity
so if your car was destroyed by the
hurricane
I might cannibalize one wheel at my car
and my family of four could have fresh
water for like three months normally if
you take aluminum and you expose it to
water nothing happens and that's because
there's a protective oxide layer coating
the aluminum surface turns out that if
you take these same bb's and you apply a
minimal coating of gallium and indium
and the right percentages it actually
becomes super exothermically reactive
with water these little bubbles that
you're seeing are hydrogen
[Music]
and actually this point I'm gonna stick
it in the fume hood here just because
it's getting a bit too hard to hold
what I'm doing is I'm using that energy
to desalinate water and provide
electricity this is the desalinator
there are no extra components needed no
electricity is required it has
essentially no moving parts this is an
incredibly robust way to produce clean
water almost immediately all of that
hydrogen and steam and heat that's
produced goes into generating really
high pressures and here's about 2,000
psi that pressure pushes down this
piston which forces seawater through a
semipermeable membrane so it's a process
called reverse osmosis right and then
the really cool thing is that after I've
desalination whatever volume of what I
want to do cell in it I have all this
hydrogen's pressurized hydrogen leftover
so what I do is I just open up this
valve and I divert the hydrogen into a
fuel cell and now I have electricity
Wow so there's still a ways to go before
you can just take any old aluminum and
do it what I'm saying here but in the
lab it works totally great
[Music]